Hey guys, I got a mouthful of English muffin with a glass full of apple juice here on the rocks. Thank you very much. And I'm here with my surprise guest today, who is a clapping sea lion. Oh my God. This is by the way, before Jason and Willow on. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less.
嘿，伙加，我嘴里塞满了英式玛芬，手里端着一杯加冰的苹果汁。非常感谢。今天和我一起的是我的神秘嘉宾，他是一只拍手的海狮。哦天哪。顺便说一句，这是在杰森和威洛上节目之前。欢迎来到 SmartLess。Smart。Less。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。
Crazy. I can't see surprise guest yet. Maybe the camera's off. No, you're not supposed to. Wait, how does it work? You're not supposed to. By the way, he won't stop clapping. Oh, but we got a live one?
太疯狂了。我还看不到神秘嘉宾。也许摄像头关了。不，你本来就不应该。等等，这是怎么运作的？你不应该。顺便说一句，他一直拍个不停。哦，不过我们有个活的？
Yeah, we got a live one. Oh boy. Might want to just get right to this guest and do our chat afterwards. We got some falling work going on over here. We had, by the way, what a wonderful dinner we had last night. We had a nice dinner, didn't we? The three of us.
对，我们有个活的。哦天哪。也许应该直接找这位嘉宾，然后再聊天。我们这边有些下坠的工作在进行。我们，顺便说一句，昨天晚上我们吃了多么棒的晚餐啊。我们吃了一顿美餐，不是吗？我们三个。
It was gorgeous. We really did. Listen, you know, the three of us don't really get a chance to have just a three top, you know? Yeah. It's very rare. Not since the early 90s, yeah. It went really well. Sean generously picked up the bill, you know. It's very rare. Not since the early 90s, yeah. It went really well.
太棒了。真的。听着，你知道，我们三个其实很难得有机会只聚三个人，你知道吗？对。非常罕见。自 90 年代初以来就没有过了，对。进展非常顺利。肖恩非常慷慨地买单了，你知道。非常罕见。自 90 年代初以来就没有过了，对。进展非常顺利。
Sean generously picked up the bill. I know. Kind of sneaky like. Very sneaky like. I know, I gotta be honest. I enjoy doing it. I know, I know it's nice to do, but consider this sometimes,
肖恩非常慷慨地买单。我知道。有点鬼鬼祟祟的。非常鬼鬼祟祟的。我知道，说实话。我很享受这么做。我知道，我知道这样做很好，但有时考虑一下，
and again, I don't want this to seem like I'm being ungrateful because it was very nice of you, so thank you. This is all dressed up in a thank you. But keep in mind. I got a heart out in five mind, other people might want to have the opportunity to do that as well. And so you don't want to take away from other people
话说回来，我不想显得不知感恩，因为你真的很好，所以谢谢你。这些话全都是包裹在感谢之中的。但请记住。我五分钟后还有急事，其他人可能也想有这样的机会。所以你不想剥夺其他人
the ability to, yeah. Save it. Will's got about the fucking shortest fucking T-Rex arms you'll ever find at a dinner table. This fucking guy, you could fucking, you could drop a check on fire in front of him and he wouldn't bat it out. He wouldn't touch it.
的机会，是的。省省吧。威尔在餐桌上有着他妈的短得要命的霸王龙手臂。这个该死的家伙，你他妈的，你可以在他面前扔一张着火的账单，他连拍都不会拍一下。他根本不会碰它。
He'd just let it catch his fucking pants on fire before he touched a burning check. That is so untrue. That is patently untrue. Oh, I can't, Sean, one of the crew members just walked through. Yeah, a bear just walked through your living room. A bear crew member. Not speaking of livestock,
他会任由火烧到他妈的裤子上，也不肯去碰一张烧着的账单。这太不真实了。这绝对是不真实的。哦，我不行，肖恩，刚才有个剧组人员走过去了。对，一头熊刚穿过你的客厅。一头熊剧组人员。说到家畜，
we ate a lot of cooked cow last night. I know, yeah. And I woke up at 2.30 in the morning and had to chug Pepto Bismol because my stomach is so unused to, it was like a four pound steak. I put it in my face. Wasn't that so good going down though? Oh yeah, it was great.
我们昨晚吃了很多煮熟的牛。我知道，是的。我凌晨两点半醒来，不得不猛灌健胃乐，因为我的胃太不习惯了，那就像是一块四磅重的牛排。我把它塞进嘴里。不过吞下去的时候不是感觉棒极了吗？哦对，太棒了。
No, I love that. It was so good. Actually, you know what, Sean, after you left us, we went and tried, we were both stuffed, we were tired as we know, we only went five more blocks. That fucking steak sandwich. We went to Bradley's house and he's got a steak, you know, he's opening a steak sandwich shop
不，我喜欢那样。太棒了。其实，你知道吗，肖恩，你离开我们之后，我们去试了试，我们两个都吃饱了，我们都很累，正如我们所知，我们又走了五个街区。那该死的牛排三明治。我们去了布拉德利家，他有一个牛排，你知道，他正在开一家牛排三明治店
in the Lower East Side. Yeah, so good. By the way, he made them for all of us. Danny and Coops, something like that? I think that's right, is it Danny and Coops? Check it out, I think it's on Avenue A, he said. Yeah, in the Lower East Side, it makes just. So good.
在下东区。对，太棒了。顺便说一句，他给我们所有人都做了。丹尼和库普斯，诸如此类的？我想是的，是丹尼和库普斯吗？去看看吧，我想是在 A 大街上，他说。对，在下东区，做得正好。太棒了。
I think, what did he say on the menu? It's just steak sandwiches. Yeah, either with cheese or without, period. No, with onions or without. Oh, God, right, right. It's going to be huge. So Sean, so after that meal we had last night, J-Sai go over there, and then Bradley's literally cooking
我想，他在菜单上是怎么说的？就只有牛排三明治。对，要么加芝士，要么不加，句号。不，加洋葱或不加。哦，天哪，对，对。这绝对会火的。所以肖恩，昨晚吃完那顿饭后，杰·赛去那边，然后布拉德利真的在自己家里
these up in his house, and he goes, here we go, and he's got his kids there and a bunch of other people, and he's like, here you go, and we're like, no, man, we just had an absolute feast. And then within 20 minutes, JB gets up. And has been, well, no wonder you got up at 2.30 in the morning. Well, but, because he walked me through the whole process of how he got the recipe from this guy
做这些，他说，来吧，他的孩子和一堆其他人都在那，他就说，给你吧，我们就说，不，老兄，我们刚吃了一顿绝对的大餐。然后在 20 分钟内，JB 就站起来了。难怪你凌晨两点半会起来。好吧，但是，因为他向我详细讲述了他是如何从这个家伙那里得到食谱的
who makes the best steak sandwiches in Philadelphia. And then, you know, Bradley like perfected it over like a year, because he just loved these sandwiches so much and he taught himself how to cook them. And then approached the guy to open up an annex. It's so good. You know, basically.
这个人做出了费城最好吃的牛排三明治。然后，你知道，布拉德利花了一年左右的时间将其完美化，因为他太喜欢这些三明治了，自学了怎么做。然后联系那个人去开一家分店。太棒了。基本上。
Don't you remember, he made them for us like, I don't know, eight, nine months ago. But they were so good. Yes, I do remember. Anyway, it was really, and I ended up having one too and they were absolutely delicious. And I walked back because. First of all, I got two things to say about it.
你不记得了吗，他大概在八、九个月前给我们做过。但它们太好吃了。是的，我记得。不管怎样，真的很棒，我最后也吃了一个，绝对美味。我走回去是因为。首先，关于这个我有两点要说。
So when we got it from the, number one, when we got it from the table last night at dinner, Jason, you pulled aside and said, I gotta run in the bathroom quick. So me and Will went outside and waited for you. I should have thrown it all up at that point and just taken it all out of me. In for you. And then- I should have thrown it all up at that point. I should have taken it all out of me. Oh my God.
所以当我们昨天在晚餐的桌上拿到它时，杰森，你把我拉到一边说，我得快去趟洗手间。所以我和威尔走到外面等你。我当时应该把一切都吐出来的，把它们全部从我体内排出去。为你。然后——我当时应该把一切都吐出来的。我应该把它全排出来的。哦天哪。
And then we're standing there and then you come out and both Will and I are like, wait a minute, who's this fucking guy coming up talking to us out of the blue? He's like, it's crazy. And I thought, where's JB? I guess I'm like, I'm thinking- You're like, who's this twink?
然后我们站在那儿，接着你出来了，威尔和我都在想，等一下，这个突兀地走过来跟我们搭话的该死的家伙是谁？他就像是，太疯狂了。我在想，JB在哪？我想我当时在想——你就像是在说，这个小白脸是谁？
Yeah. Yeah, listener. You wish, you wish you were a twink. Well, I don't. And he's kind of like, who's this twink? Yeah. I told you I'm not. You wish. You wish you were a twink. Well, I don't even know what a twink is. Is that, is it good or bad? No, you got it. No, you're a twink.
对。对，听众朋友。你想得美，你才希望自己是个小白脸。好吧，我不想。而他有点像，这个小白脸是谁？对。我告诉过你我不是。你想得美。你想得美，你才希望是个小白脸。好吧，我甚至不知道什么是小白脸。那是，是好是坏？不，你懂的。不，你就是个小白脸。
So listener, they're talking about, because I've had my, I've looked like Jesus Christ for the last nine months, basically, because I'm playing this guy with long hair and long beard and all that stuff. And I just cut it all off because we came to the end of the thing. The number of people, and Sean, you're probably the same,
所以听众朋友，他们说的是，因为我差不多有九个月的时间，我都留着胡子，看起来就像耶稣基督一样，因为我演的这个角色有着长头发和长胡子之类的一切。而我刚刚把它全剃了，因为拍摄结束了。那些人，肖恩，你可能也一样，
who have come up to me, as if I'm your wife over the last six months ago, hey, or texted me, people have gone so far, they're like, hey, what's up with Jason? How come his hair is so long? And I'm like, he's an actor, what are you? But they all assume, I love that nobody assumes that I would be doing it for any sort of acting part.
过去六个月里走到我面前，就像我是你老婆一样，嘿，或者发短信给我，人们甚至走得更远，他们会说，嘿，杰森怎么了？为什么他头发那么长？我就想，他是个演员，你是什么？但他们都假设，我喜欢没人假设我会为了任何演艺角色而这么做。
Like they don't even think. Nobody thinks you're in trouble. Everybody thinks I'm in trouble. They go there instead of like, well, he's not much of a thespian, he's not gonna change his look for a part. He must've just hit fuck it and we've gotta send him some money.
就好像他们根本没想。没人觉得你有麻烦。所有人觉得我有麻烦。他们直接那样想，而不是觉得，好吧，他算不上什么戏剧演员，他才不会为了一个角色改变造型。他肯定只是豁出去了，我们得给他汇点钱。
Why did Marty Berg grow his hair? But anyway. And then you dropped me off and then we said, I'm sending him some money. Why did Marty Berg grow his hair? But anyway. And then you dropped me off and then we sat, I went, I'm like, well, where's Uptown? Cause I'm so lost downtown, like I don't understand. And he goes, just go that way. I was walking for like 20 minutes. I'm like, I don't have to know why.
马蒂·伯格为什么留长发？但不管怎样。然后你把我放下，然后我们说，我给他汇点钱。马蒂·伯格为什么留长发？但不管怎样。然后你把我放下，然后我们坐着，我说，我在想，上城在哪里？因为我对市中心太迷茫了，我都搞不懂。然后他说，往那边走就行了。我走了大约 20 分钟。我想，我不需要知道为什么。
He was a half a block from 8th Avenue and he walked all the way into the Hudson River. I was, I have no idea where I was. I was scared out of my mind. And then I asked these four people, I'm like, do you know where like Uptown, like which direction Uptown is? Well, first give us your wallet.
他离第八大道只有半个街区，结果一路走进了哈德逊河。我当时，我完全不知道自己在哪里。我吓得魂飞魄散。然后我问了四个人，我说，你知道上城大概，哪个方向是上城吗？好吧，先把钱包交出来。
You got mugged and then- You ask people which direction Uptown is? I know. It was a young married couple and then in-laws. And the married couple was like, yeah, you go that way. And then the mom of the in-laws goes, oh my God, Will and Grace. And then the two young married couple and then in-laws. And the married couple was like, yeah, you go that way. And then the mom of the in-laws goes, oh my God, Will and Grace. And then the two young married couples like,
你被打劫了，然后——你问别人哪个方向是上城？我知道。那是一对年轻夫妻，还有亲家。那对夫妻说，对，你往那边走。然后亲家的妈妈说，哦天哪，威尔与格蕾丝。然后那对年轻夫妻，还有亲家。这对夫妻说，对，你往那边走。然后亲家的妈妈说，哦天哪，威尔与格蕾丝。然后那两个年轻夫妻就像，
oh my God, smartless. And then the dad goes, just to make sure, to keep me real, he goes, I don't know who the hell you are. Right? And I go. I go, I don't know. Isn't that the funniest instinct that people have? I've had people come up and go like, hey, my friends want to pick, I have no idea you,
哦天哪，SmartLess。然后爸爸说，为了确保万无一失，为了让我认清现实，他说，我根本不知道你他妈是谁。对吧？然后我说。我说，我不知道。人们这种本能是不是超级搞笑？我以前遇到过有人走过来，说，嘿，我朋友想要个合影，我根本不知道你是谁，
I want to know, pick you out of a lineup of one. I could not care less. You're zero to me. Yeah, you're zero, that's basically what's going on. But anyway, they want to get it picked, and you're like, okay, well, thanks for telling me, man. I didn't ask. Anyway, let's get into our guest.
我想知道，在一对一的列队里把你挑出来。我才不在乎呢。你在我眼里就是零。对，你就是零，基本上就是这么回事。不过不管怎样，他们想拍一个，然后你就想，好吧，谢谢你告诉我，老兄。我可没问。不管怎样，让我们欢迎我们的嘉宾吧。
He's been waiting long enough. Honestly, Sean, I feel like, why are you crying? This is like, we've on Earth, okay, let's not get into it. Okay, this guy makes me laugh so hard. I love this guy. We've got a lot in common, both Midwestern boys, large Irish families. Interesting fact, he's been in over 200 commercials.
他已经等得够久了。说实话，肖恩，我觉得，你为什么在哭？这就像是，我们活在世上，好吧，别扯这个了。好吧，这家伙把我逗得太厉害了。我很喜欢这家伙。我们有很多共同点，都是中西部男孩，都有庞大的爱尔兰家庭。有趣的事实是，他拍过 200 多个广告。
He's performed for the Pope. I think that means stand up. And how when he was- 200 commercials, that's amazing. And how when he was eight, he stood in line for two hours to meet Jimmy Walker from Good Times just to have him sign dynamite. Well today, we get the other explosive Jimmy guys.
他为教皇表演过。我想那是指单口喜剧。还有当他—— 200 个广告，太惊人了。还有当他八岁时，他排了两个小时的队去见《美好时光》里的吉米·沃克，只为了让他签下“炸药”二字。好吧，今天，我们请到了另一位充满爆发力的吉米。
It's the brilliant, the prolific, the funny, the lovable Jim Gaffigan, who we love. Jim Gaffigan. Who we love. Jim Gaffigan, wow. Hello there, I'm a big fan of yours. Oh shucks, geez. You know what's so weird is you guys went to dinner last night and I don't know why,
他就是才华横溢、多产、搞笑、讨人喜欢的吉姆·加菲根，我们都爱他。吉姆·加菲根。我们都爱他。吉姆·加菲根，哇。你好啊，我是你的超级粉丝。哦天哪，哎呀。你知道最奇怪的是什么吗，你们昨晚去吃晚餐了，我不知道为什么，
and I think the listeners should know this, that you made me be the waiter, which I thought was strange. Well, just as a rehearsal. Yeah, hear us out, Jim. We just figured that we know how real you like to keep it. I mean, a lot of people should know that Sean Hayes does not tip at the whole.
我觉得听众们应该知道这一点，你们让我当服务员，我觉得这很奇怪。好吧，就当是彩排。听我们说，吉姆。我们只是觉得我们了解你有多喜欢保持真实。我的意思是，很多人应该知道肖恩·海斯给小费从来都不全。
Not financially. I said, is this it? Do you need change? And he said, I need you to change your attitude. And I said, all right. Now, Jim, do you still have that autograph I need you to change your attitude. And I was like, all right. Oh my God. Jim, do you still have that autograph that says dynamite from Jimmy Walker?
不是在经济上。我说，就这些吗？需要找零吗？他说，我需要你改变你的态度。我说，好吧。现在，吉姆，你还留着那个我需要你改变你的态度。我说，好吧。哦天哪。吉姆，你还留着吉米·沃克签有“炸药”字样的那个签名吗？
No, no. Damn it. I love that. I only remember that because I saw a photo of it. Cause I had a dynamite hat. Yeah, sure. I'm probably older than all you guys. But like, there was a big,
没有，没有。真该死。我太喜欢了。我只记得那个，因为我见过一张照片。因为我有一顶“炸药”帽子。对，当然。我可能比你们所有人都老。不过，有一个巨大的，
I mean, Will looks the oldest, but like the big... Wait a second. Wait a second. Do we? No, I think it's... Will could be like... Well, I think Will would be... There is...
我的意思是，威尔看起来最老，但是那个巨大的……等一下。等一下。我们是吗？不，我觉得是……威尔可能就像……好吧，我觉得威尔会是……这里有……
A lot of people don't know he's doing a movie where he's playing Gavin Newsom's dad. Yeah. Wow. This is the Arnett roast. Will, we didn't want to tell you before we got started. You know, Will, I just do that because I'm scared. Why? Frankly, I'm a little scared.
很多人不知道他正在拍一部电影，在里面饰演加文·纽森的爸爸。对。哇。这是对阿奈特的吐槽。威尔，在我们开始之前我们不想告诉你。你知道，威尔，我这么做只是因为我害怕。为什么？坦白说，我有点害怕。
I'm intimidated. Why? Three buddies, I'm the new kid. I don't know how to fit in. You're so safe here. You're already fitting in beautifully. The dirty little secret about this podcast is it really doesn't matter who we have on as a guest
我有压力。为什么？三个好兄弟，我是新来的。我不知道怎么融入。你在这里很安全。你已经融入得非常完美了。这个播客不可告人的小秘密是，我们请谁来当嘉宾其实根本不重要，
because we don't let them talk anyway. We just like to hear ourselves talk. You're on cruise control for the next hour. Right. Or 45. Jim, we don't know each other well, but you came up to very kindly to Canada and did that hospital benefit.
因为反正我们也不让他们说话。我们只是喜欢听自己说话。接下来的一小时你都可以开启巡航模式了。对。或者 45 分钟。吉姆，我们虽然不是很熟，但你非常友善地来到加拿大参加了那个医院慈善义演。
Do you remember that? Is that right? Yeah, or did you block it out? No, I remember it. I remember it very clearly. He was, you were hilarious. Oh, thanks. Absolutely crushed.
你还记得吗？是这样吗？对，还是说你把它选择性失忆了？不，我记得。我记得非常清楚。他当时，你太搞笑了。哦，谢谢。绝对全场爆笑。
Always is. And you always crush, yeah. I know, cause you've been telling me. He never pushes, never pushes. Just trying to get my dad to like me. And I don't know if it's gonna work. Is dad still with us? No, he's been dead for like 20 years.
一直如此。你总是能炸场，对。我知道，因为你一直在告诉我。他从不勉强，从不勉强。只是想让我爸喜欢我。我不知道这管不管用。爸爸还在我们身边吗？不，他已经去世大约 20 年了。
You're waiting for a message? He's right over here. He's just off camera. When you hear that... Wake up! I've been telling him every morning, I'm like, wake up. He's really tired. He's really tired.
你在等他的消息？他就坐在旁边。就在镜头外面。当你听到那个……醒醒！我每天早上都对他说，醒醒吧。他真的很累。他真的很累。
He just put new ice on him every day. Yeah, he's just... Hey, well, how did you get... How did you get to be in 200 commercials? I'm actually envious of that. I was on this show, Silver Spoons. No. And then?
他只是每天给他换新冰块。对，他只是……嘿，威尔，你是怎么……你是怎么拍了 200 个广告的？其实我挺嫉妒这个的。我当时演了这部剧，《天才保姆》。不。然后呢？
No, there was an era in the 90s where they really loved the idea of the dumb white guy in every commercial. And I was like, I'll do that. Sean wasn't available. I did those too, I did a ton of them. There's a lot of dumb white guy in every commercial. And I was like, I'll do that. Sean wasn't available. I did those too, I did a ton of them. There's a lot of dumb white guy work. I immediately started thinking, oh wait, this is one of those guys
不，90 年代有一个时期，他们非常喜欢每个广告里都有一个愚蠢的白痴男子的设定。我就想，那我去演。肖恩当时没空。我也演过那些，我演了一大堆。有很多愚蠢白痴男子的活。我马上开始想，哦等等，这家伙就是那种
that's got one of those campaigns. It's like the Jack in a Box guy. The progressive girl. Yeah, exactly. It would add up quickly. Yes, I did Rolling Rock and Saturn, which was a car company. And this is back in the days when they would pay, right?
手握某个广告大牌代言的人。就像杰克盒子先生。进步保险公司的那个女孩。对，没错。积累起来会很快。是的，我拍过滚石啤酒和土星汽车，那是一家汽车公司。那是以前还会付钱的年代，对吧？
You could get about 30 grand It was life changing. by the time a national commercial is done with its cycle, right? Wasn't it about, you could count on about $30,000. Absolutely. How many brands did you sink, do you think? I would say.
当一个全国播出的广告走完它的周期时，你可以拿到大约 3 万美元，对吧？这能改变生活。难道不是吗，你大概可以指望得到大约 3 万美元。绝对是的。你觉得你砸了多少个牌子？我可以说。
Rolling Rock for one. Saturn for two. I definitely sink. Wait, Jimmy, so you were born in Elgin, Illinois. That's so crazy. Is it Jimmy? Yeah, it's Jimmy. When I was a little kid, I was Jimmy.
一个滚石啤酒。两个土星汽车。我绝对砸过。等等，吉米，所以你出生在伊利诺伊州的埃尔金。太疯狂了。是吉米吗？对，是吉米。我小时候叫吉米。
Now, where are you from, Sean? Glen Ellyn, so it's like 20 minutes from Elgin. Yeah, well we moved pretty quickly to Northwest Indiana. I mean, when I was eight, I guess. And you wanted to be a farmer? I did. What kind of, what did you want to farm? You know, I think corn.
那么，肖恩，你来自哪里？格伦埃尔林，离埃尔金大概 20 分钟。对，我们很快就搬到了印第安纳州西北部。我是说，大概在我八岁的时候。你想当个农民？我是。你想种什么，你想种什么？你知道的，我想是玉米。
I just, it's weird. I, it's a pretty big dream. Not soybeans. You had. It was a- Not something sexy like soybeans or rye, but like corn, you know, like a big dream. And not soybeans. Yeah. It was a... Not something sexy like soybeans or rye, but like corn, you know, like a normal plant. No, I did want to be a farmer,
我只是，这很奇怪。我，这是一个相当宏大的梦想。不是大豆。你拥有。那是一个——不是大豆或黑麦那样性感的东西，而是玉米，你知道的，一个宏大的梦想。而且不是大豆。对。那是一个——不是大豆或黑麦那样性感的东西，而是玉米，你知道的，一种普通的植物。不，我确实想当个农民，
and then, but I also wanted to be an actor in a community. I know, like early on, like, and your dad was the CEO of the Mercantile National Bank of Indiana, which is so crazy. And then you wanted to be, and what did he think of you wanting to be an actor? He thought it was pretty fucking stupid. Oh, sure.
然后，但我也想在社区里当个演员。我知道，就像很早以前，你爸爸是印第安纳州水银国家银行的首席执行官，这太疯狂了。然后你想成为，他怎么看你想当演员这件事？他觉得这他妈简直蠢透了。哦，当然。
No, it was, my parents were children of, their parents went through the depression, so the whole objective was to seek security. And I think my family had been in the country and my father was the first one to go to college. But before that, everyone was coal miners. So it was just like, we finally got to the middle class and you wanna become a show person?
不，是这样的，我的父母是经历过大萧条的人的孩子，所以全部的目标就是追求安全感。我想我的家族一直都在乡下，我父亲是第一个上大学的人。但在此之前，所有人都是煤矿工人。所以这就好像，我们好不容易跨入了中产阶级，而你想去当个演艺人员？
It was just absurd. It was like, why throw it away? Yeah, but it's interesting because this happens all the time, we talk about this all the time. You're the youngest of six, I'm the youngest of five, and it seems to be, like a lot of people we talk to, the youngest in the family always wants to be
这简直荒谬。就好像为什么要把它扔掉？是的，但很有趣，因为这种事一直在发生，我们一直在谈论这个。你是六个孩子里最小的，我是五个孩子里最小的，似乎就像我们谈论过的很多人一样，家里最小的孩子总是想成为
the actor or the performer or the attention seeker, I guess. Isn't that weird? Well, the alcoholism was so significant by the time we were teenagers. Yeah, same. Were you close with your dad? My dad was this huge influence on me, but it was weird. I think it was mostly trying to make my mom laugh,
演员、表演者，或者是寻求关注的人，我猜。这不是很奇怪吗？好吧，等我们十几岁的时候，酗酒情况已经非常严重了。对，我也是。你跟你爸亲近吗？我爸对我有巨大的影响，但很奇怪。我想这主要是为了逗我妈笑，
but the whole father relationship is so complex. And again, I think, I don't know about with you, there was such a parental fatigue that it hit by the time I was a teenager. My dad was like, I didn't even sign up for any of this. You know what I mean? And having children myself, I'm kind of like, can they go to boarding school or middle school?
但整个父子关系实在是太复杂了。而且再次觉得，我想，不知道你是不是这样，等我十几岁的时候，已经有一种强烈的父母疲劳感了。我爸就像是，我可没报名参加这一切。你知道我的意思吗？而且我自己有了孩子之后，我有时会想，他们能去寄宿学校或初中吗？
Can they do that? It's just, it's exhausting, right? And so. You say you do have children yourself, or you don't? Yes, yes, I have five. I have five. Oh my God, wow. I know, that's a lot of kids.
他们能去那种地方吗？这真的是，太让人筋疲力尽了，对吧？所以。你说你确实有孩子，还是没有？对，对，我有五个。我有五个孩子。哦天哪，哇。我知道，这有很多孩子。
So I'm a very fertile guy. How old is your youngest, Jim? He just turned 12. Oh wow. Wow. And I feel like with every kid, there was a reason for me to like him. You're like, all right, this one likes me so much.
所以我是一个非常多产的家伙。你的老幺多大了，吉姆？他刚满 12 岁。哦哇。哇。我觉得每个孩子出生，都有一个让我喜欢他的理由。你会想，好吧，这个这么喜欢我。
I like him. And then my youngest one looks like me. And so I'm like, all right, I got a mini me. I got to be excited about that. It is amazing, right? Like how you have, you develop these different relationships with the kids based on completely different stuff.
我喜欢他。然后我老幺长得像我。所以我就想，好吧，我有个迷你版的自己。我得为此感到兴奋。这太惊人了，对吧？就像你拥有，你根据完全不同的事情与孩子们发展出这些不同的关系。
I mean, I know you're kind of making a half a joke, but like there is something to be said for like, well, the initial bond started because that little thing that couldn't speak or do anything yet has an attraction to me. And there's a, it's almost like a puppy. Like kids are like puppies before they can speak. Right?
我的意思是，我知道你有点在开半个玩笑，但确实有那么一回事，比如说，最初的羁绊开始于那个还不会说话、什么都不会做的小东西对你产生了吸引力。而且有一种，它几乎就像一只小狗。就像小孩子们在会说话之前就像小狗一样。对吧？
And it's like, oh, they jump on my lap all the time. And so, well, I like you too. And now you're my favorite pet. Right? Yeah, and then your role changes. And you're like, okay, I'm the peacekeeper between, because daughters and mothers go through some weird crap, and now I'm kind of buttress buttress golly here,
就好像，哦，他们总是跳到我膝盖上。所以，好吧，我也喜欢你。现在你是我最喜欢的宠物了。对吧？是的，然后你的角色就变了。你会想，好吧，我是个和平缔造者，因为女儿和母亲之间会经历一些奇怪的破事，现在我有点像这里的顶梁柱，
trying to keep some peace. And then there's just different ones where you're like, all right, I'm the evil cop that has to be the disciplinarian. Yeah, or the one kid's actually less like a puppy and much more like a cat. So they're difficult, they don't give you the time of day. So you end up being very drawn to that one.
试图维持一些和平。然后还有各种不同的情况，你会想，好吧，我成了必须扮演纪律维护者的恶警。是的，或者其中一个孩子其实不怎么像小狗，反而更像猫。所以他们很难搞，根本不搭理你。所以你最后会被那种吸引。
I got to win that one over, right? Independent. I know you've got almost a half to that one. You know, I got to win that one over, right? Independent. I mean, I know you've got almost a half a dozen there. It must be. My relationship with my kids is so good. I don't have to like worry about roles. We just kind of click. Sorry, I just wanted to.
我得把那个争取过来，对吧？独立。我知道你那边快有半打孩子了。一定是的。我和我孩子们的关系太好了。我不需要担心什么角色。我们就是那种一拍即合。抱歉，我只是想……
Just click, click, click, right? Hey, Jim, you don't really think I look older than the other guys, do you? No, no. Let's double back a little bit. Tuck on that. Okay, thank God. Now, Jim, where are you?
就是一拍即合，对吧？嘿，吉姆，你真的不觉得我看起来比其他几个人老吧？不，不。让我们稍微回过头去。再提一下。好吧，谢天谢地。现在，吉姆，你在哪？
Are you in Los Angeles, New York? I'm in New York. Yeah, all right. I live in New York. Oh, that's cool. Have you been in New York a long time? I've been here for 35 years. I've done some time in,
你在洛杉矶还是纽约？我在纽约。对，好吧。我住在纽约。哦，那挺酷的。你在纽约呆了很久了吗？我在这里呆了 35 年了。我花了一些时间在，
when I was on a show, I would be in LA for six months or six weeks. I did pilot season. Oh yeah, every year. Now, your time in Los Angeles, is this something you kind of hold your nose and kind of get through it, or do you like it out there? I don't have anything against Los Angeles.
当我参演某部剧时，我会在洛杉矶呆六个月或六周。我经历过试播季。哦对，每年都有。现在，你在洛杉矶的那段时间，是你捏着鼻子熬过去的，还是你挺喜欢那里的？我对洛杉矶没有什么意见。
I mean, I'm not a fan of sunlight, but I'm very much, too much show business is not good for my mental health. Like that's what I like about New York, that like you have friends that are not in the business and you can kind of separate yourself from it, if that makes sense. Yeah.
我是说，我不是阳光的粉丝，但我非常觉得，太多的娱乐圈对我的心理健康没有好处。这就是我喜欢纽约的地方，你有一些不属于这个圈子的朋友，你可以把自己从中抽离出来，如果这说得通的话。对。
And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Do you ever worry that like by having that healthy And now back to the show. Do you ever worry that like by having that healthy kind of distance from show business and the pursuit of it and all that stuff that you run the risk of not going to the places that you want to go career wise? I ask because these guys always keep me in check and give me proper ridicule about how sort of
我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。你有没有担心过，通过与娱乐圈、对它的追求以及所有这些保持那种健康的、现在回到节目中。你有没有担心过，通过与娱乐圈、对它的追求以及所有这些保持那种健康的距离，你会有在职业生涯上无法到达你想去的地方的风险？我之所以这么问，是因为这群家伙总是把我管得死死的，对我在商业上保持着怎样的敏锐度、接下来应该做什么诸如此类的事情进行恰当的嘲弄。
keeping my eye on the ball I am about like, what's happening in the business tree and what should I be doing next and all that stuff. I can't help it but I envy those that have a healthy distance from it. You also grew up in it so it's a little different in that way. Yeah, I feel like I've definitely,
我忍不住，但我很羡慕那些能与之保持健康距离的人。你也是在里面长大的，所以在这方面有点不同。对，我觉得我绝对，
I think my career might be completely different if I lived in L.A. I mean, it is 99% of the business, but it's also, I don't want to sound like the person, you know, like there's, you know, like, I'm not like Sam Shepard said, I'm on a farm in Virginia. Right, yeah.
我觉得如果我住在洛杉矶，我的职业生涯可能会完全不同。我是说，这占了生意的 99%，但这也是，我不想听起来像那种人，你知道的，就像有，你知道的，就像，我不像山姆·谢泼德说的，我在弗吉尼亚的一个农场里。对，没错。
And you can fax me only. You know what I mean? It's like, I wish I could be that guy. I mean, I definitely care. I'm definitely the guy who's, you know, works really, I'm the guy who does his homework. You know what I mean? I'm not like, I don't even know,
而且你只能给我发传真。你知道我的意思吗？这就好像，我希望我能成为那种人。我是说，我绝对在乎。我绝对是那种，你知道的，工作非常努力的人，我是那种会做家庭作业的人。你知道我的意思吗？我不是那种，我甚至不知道，
I don't even know my agent's name. No, yeah, you've been able to stay so relevant for so long. You've had this really long career, and yet you've been able to live outside of it to a certain extent, yeah? Oh, thanks. Yeah, good for you. It's admirable.
我甚至不知道我经纪人的名字。不，对，你能够保持如此长时间的活跃度。你有着非常长的职业生涯，然而你却能在某种程度上活在它之外，对吧？哦，谢谢。对，真为你高兴。这令人钦佩。
Jim, how many years, what was your first break, and how many years have you been doing stand-up? I've been doing it for like 35 years. And was it always stand-up first or was it an actor first and then you wanted it? It was a little bit of both, but it was, I would say, yeah. Stand-up was something I always did, but I always wanted to act, and but there's such fantastic actors in New York.
吉姆，多少年了，你的第一次突破是什么，你做单口喜剧多少年了？我做这个大概 35 年了。一直都是单口喜剧优先，还是先当演员然后才想做这个？两者都有点，但它是，我想是的。单口喜剧是我一直在做的，但我总是想演戏，但纽约有太多出色的演员了。
So like. Yeah, but the Jim Gaffigan show was hilarious. But wait, I want to get to the stand up. First of all, what was the first night? What was the first time you were like in front of the people? The first time I was so, you know, there's such an audacity necessary to go into this business, right?
所以就像。对，但《吉姆·加菲根秀》太搞笑了。等等，我想聊聊单口喜剧。首先，那是怎样的一个夜晚？你第一次站在人们面前是什么时候？第一次的时候我太，你知道的，进入这个行业需要极大的厚脸皮，对吧？
But also with stand up to go on stage, I waited until someone dared me. I had a fear of public speaking, so I took an improv class, this is way before UCB existed, and in the improv class, someone was like, there's a standup seminar, this is in 1990, 1991.
但对于单口喜剧来说，上台演出，我一直等到有人向我下战书。我有公开演讲的恐惧症，所以我上了一个即兴表演班，这在 UCB（宇宙城剧团）出现之前很久了，在即兴表演班里，有人说，有一个单口喜剧研讨会，那是在 1990 年、1991 年。
Is this New York or Chicago? New York. Okay. And then I, so I did stand up for the first time and it was, I fell in love immediately. And then, how about that? Kind of bombed for six months. Yeah.
这是在纽约还是芝加哥？纽约。好吧。然后我，所以我第一次表演单口喜剧，那是，我立刻就爱上了。然后，怎么样？搞砸了大概六个月。对。
Did you write jokes that first time or did you just kind of wing it? What'd you do? Oh yeah, no, I did this, it was kind of like a seminar thing. It was like someone really holding your hand. It was, yeah, it wasn't like me and my buddies went to a club and I got on stage and it was magic.
你第一次是写了笑话还是临时发挥的？你做了什么？哦，是的，不，我做了这个，有点像研讨会一样的东西。就好像有人真的在手把手教你。那是，是的，不是我和哥们儿去俱乐部，然后我上台表演，然后就创造了奇迹。
Do you still, like, what is the oldest joke that you still have in your rotation? Like still one from that from the from the early years at all. I mean, it's it's I I you know at this point I You know, I haven't done jokes from Back then for for at least a decade and so sometimes I'll write a joke and I'll think, oh, this is great. And then, you know, my wife will be like, you know that was on like your third special, that joke. I'm like, oh, all right.
你现在还，你还在表演的最老的笑话是什么？比如还有早期那些年留下来的一两个。我是说，它，我，你知道，到了这个时候，我，你知道，我已经有至少十年没讲过当年那些笑话了，所以有时候我写了一个笑话，我会想，哦，这太棒了。然后，你知道，我老婆会说，你知道那个在你第三个专场里就用过了吗，那个笑话。我就想，哦，好吧。
You know, like, I don't even remember that. I had done a joke. You already complained about your kids that way. It's all right. Does she dabble in our industry as well? Yes, yes. So she was the So she did directing and she also was the showrunner of the Jim Gaffigan show.
你知道的，就像，我甚至都不记得了。我以前讲过一个笑话。你已经那样抱怨过你的孩子了。没关系。她也涉足我们的行业吗？是的，是的。所以她是，所以她搞导演，她也是《吉姆·加菲根秀》的运作人。
And when we were, but initially when we stand up, we used to totally, once we were married, we wrote together and then with five kids with five kids, you're lucky to have a conversation with your partner. Wait, so she's showrunner for Jim Gaffigan's show, so what, you had an overall with the network or with the studio? Yeah, that was, before cable completely fell apart,
而当我们，但最初做单口喜剧时，我们完全是，结婚后，我们一起创作，然后有了五个孩子，有了五个孩子，你能和伴侣说上话就烧高香了。等等，所以她是吉姆·加菲根秀的节目运作人，所以什么，你跟电视网或制片厂签了总体协议？对，那是，在有线电视彻底崩盘之前，
even though I guess it's coming back, we had a deal at CBS, we did two rounds of pilots, they were committed to single camera comedies, and then they weren't. And so they released us, and we had an offer from a couple cable things, but the most attractive offer came from TV Land. TV Land was gonna do this massive rebranding thing,
尽管我想它现在又要卷土重来了，我们在 CBS 有个协议，我们做了两轮试播集，他们承诺要做单镜头喜剧，然后他们又不做了。所以他们解除了我们的合约，我们收到了几个有线电视台的邀约，但最具吸引力的邀约来自 TV Land 电视台。TV Land 当时要做一次大规模的品牌重塑，
and of course we were like, all right, yeah, great, and then we went over there, and then a month before the show started airing, yeah, we're not gonna do a massive rebranding. Shawnee did some TV land work, yeah? Yeah, that was the show. We did, we produced... With Betty White.
当然我们当时就想，好吧，太棒了，然后我们去了那里，结果在节目开播前一个月，是的，我们不打算搞大规模的品牌重塑了。肖尼在 TV Land 做过一些工作，对吧？对，就是那个节目。我们做了，我们制作了……与贝蒂·怀特合作。
Hot in Cleveland. Yeah, wait a minute, were you on, was Teachers, you guys, or, no, that was Melissa, I think. Hot in Cleveland with Betty White. Yeah. That was the first, I think that was the first show that launched TV land and scripted. Yeah, I think that was the big,
《热力克利夫兰》。对，等一下，你演过，是《老友记》，你们，或者，不，那是梅丽莎，我想。与贝蒂·怀特合作的《热力克利夫兰》。对。那是第一部，我想那是第一部开启 TV Land 剧本节目的剧。对，我想那是重大，
that was part of the big TV Land relaunch. Yeah, we got lucky. Wait, so what network was Jim Gaffigan's show on that I forget? It was on TV Land. It was, it was on TV Land. So you and your wife write the pilot together, or she writes the pilot? I wrote the pilot with Peter Tolan.
那是 TV Land 盛大重新推出的一部分。对，我们很幸运。等等，吉姆·加菲根的那个我忘了名字的节目是在哪个电视台播出的？是在 TV Land。是在，是在 TV Land。所以你和你老婆一起写试播集，还是她写试播集？我和彼得·托兰一起写的试播集。
Oh, yeah. Who's really funny, yeah. The great Peter Tolan. And then he was under a Sony deal, and so he couldn't go when we went to TV Land. It was really funny, yeah. The great Peter Tolen. He was under a Sony deal, and so he couldn't go when we went to TV land. I mean, sometimes they re-aired every episode on Comedy Central,
哦，对。非常搞笑，对。伟大的彼得·托兰。然后他签在索尼旗下，所以我们去 TV Land 的时候他不能去。非常搞笑，对。伟大的彼得·托兰。他当时签在索尼旗下，所以我们去 TV Land 的时候他不能去。我是说，有时候他们在喜剧中心频道重播每一集，
so that's where people would end up seeing it. Yes. So wait, so God, so much time I'm on the side with this. Oh wait, by the way, I heard you love to go to Steakhouse after each stand-up thing. I love steak, yeah. We just went to a Steakhouse after each stand-up thing. I love steak, yeah. We just went to a Steakhouse last night.
所以人们最终是在那里看到的。是的。所以等等，天哪，我在这上面花了太多时间。哦等等，顺便说一句，我听说你每次演完单口喜剧都喜欢去牛排馆。我喜欢牛排，对。我们刚刚在每次单口喜剧演出后都去了一家牛排馆。我喜欢牛排，对。我们昨晚才刚去了一家牛排馆。
Great steak last night. You ever been to Strip Steakhouse? Strip? Oh yeah. And so do you guys try, how often do you guys get together and pretend to like each other? Yeah, not very. Not that often. Too hard.
昨晚的牛排太棒了。你们去过 Strip 牛排馆吗？Strip？哦，对。所以你们俩会试着，你们俩多久聚一次并假装喜欢对方？对，不经常。没那么频繁。太难了。
We're not that good at acting. No, we have dinner quite a lot. We have dinner when we're all in town like once a week, but it's with everybody in family. Just the three of us is a rare thing. Yeah, I mean that's what's also so great about whatever I do podcast is like, it forces you to have these conversations with your friends
我们演戏没那么好。不，我们经常一起吃晚餐。只要我们都在城里，我们大概一周吃一次晚餐，但那是跟所有人还有家人一起。只有我们三个是非常罕见的。对，我的意思是这也是我做的任何播客最棒的地方，就像是，它迫使你和你的朋友进行这些对话，
because things can spin out of control and it's like getting paid to hang around your friends is not bad. That's how this started. I know you guys donate all your money. A lot of people don't know that. All the money is donated, which is amazing. Are you worried though, like, I do think about, because I love steakhouse too, like in LA.
因为事情会失控，而且这就像是拿钱和你的朋友们鬼混，感觉还不赖。这就是这个播客的起源。我知道你们把所有的钱都捐了。很多人不知道这一点。所有的钱都捐出去了，这太惊人了。不过你担心吗，比如，我也在想，因为我也喜欢牛排馆，就像在洛杉矶。
Sean still loves the steak, sorry. Yeah, I can't wait to hear what Jim might be worried about in the steakhouse industry. What does it sound? I mean, you can jump in if you want. Yeah. But I love. Please finish this.
肖恩还是喜欢牛排，抱歉。对，我等不及想听听吉姆可能会对牛排馆行业有什么担忧了。听起来会是怎样？我是说，如果你想的话可以插话。对。但我喜欢。请把这个说完。
I like the simplicity of the menu. There's like six things. Because remember Jerry's Deli in Los Angeles? Yeah, sure. You sit down. I bet Cheesecake Factory must really piss you off. Cheesecake Factory too. It's a book and it's like 200, and I almost have to get up
我喜欢菜单的简单。大概只有六样东西。因为还记得洛杉矶的杰瑞熟食店吗？对，当然。你坐下来。我敢打赌芝士蛋糕工厂一定很让你抓狂。芝士蛋糕工厂也是。它就像一本书，有 200 样东西，我几乎得站起来，
because my anxiety, like there's too many choices, I can't do it. But a steakhouse, it's like there's four things here and there's four sides, what do you want? The sauces get me pissed off at a steakhouse though. I never know which way to go. That's why I always do ketchup. I always do ketchup with my steak.
因为我的焦虑症发作了，选择太多了，我做不到。但牛排馆，就像这里有四样东西，有四种配菜，你想要哪个？不过在牛排馆里，那些酱汁让我很火大。我永远不知道该选哪种。这就是为什么我总是选番茄酱。我吃牛排总是配番茄酱。
You are Midwestern. Yeah, it really is. I like it ketchup with my steak. You are Midwestern. Yeah. I like it at a steakhouse when they kind of show you the meat or they show you a potato. We got a potato. We got this lobster flown in from Maine. It's just like-
你确实很中西部。对，确实如此。我喜欢牛排配番茄酱。你确实很中西部。对。我喜欢在牛排馆里他们给你看肉或者给你看土豆。我们有个土豆。我们有从缅因空运来的龙虾。这就好像——
Warns does that. It's like so dumb guy-ish. Like, hey, you're a dumb guy. This is a potato. We can cook it for you. I love it. Now, I know I'm jumping all around, but I want to go back to your career.
沃恩就是那样。这就好像很白痴气十足。嘿，你是个白痴。这是个土豆。我们可以为你做。我太喜欢了。现在，我知道我东拉西扯的，但我想回到你的职业生涯。
Jimmy, when you first did Beyond the Pale, that was your first stand-up special, and you had, I don't know how many after, and what blew my mind is how many Grammys you've been nominated for. What? Oh, thanks. Like, how many times have you been nominated? I think seven times.
吉米，你第一次做《超越淡然》的时候，那是你的第一个单口喜剧专场，你有很多个专场，让我震惊的是你获得了多少次格莱美提名。什么？哦，谢谢。就像，你被提名了多少次？我想有七次。
But, you know, I'm never going to win one, but like, that's, it is. But that's crazy. Why do you do nominated? I think seven times. But you know, I'm never gonna win one. But like that's, it is. But that's crazy, that's amazing. Well because some of it is like, I'm just so thrilled that the Grammys even include, you know, stand-up comedy. And in the end, there's always, you know, some very important newsworthy comedic event that's occurred,
但是，你知道，我永远不可能赢得一个，但是，这，确实。但这太疯狂了。你为什么会被提名？我想有七次。但你知道，我永远不可能赢得一个。但就像那一样，这，但这太疯狂了，太惊人了。好吧，因为其中一部分是，我真的很高兴格莱美甚至把单口喜剧包括在内。归根结底，总会有，你知道的，发生一些非常重要且具有新闻价值的喜剧事件，
you know, whether it be, you know, very important newsworthy comedic event that's occurred, whether it be Chappelle doing anything, or one year it was Weird Al Yankovic had did the first comedy album in 25 years. It's like, obviously he's going to win. You know what I mean? Right, right, right, right, right. Yeah, but I don't know. I think it's pretty-
你知道，无论是，发生了一些非常重要且具有新闻价值的喜剧事件，无论是查佩尔做任何事，还是有一年“怪咖”阿尔·扬科维奇推出了 25 年来的第一张喜剧专辑。就好像，很显然他会赢。你知道我的意思吗？对，对，对，对，对。是的，但我不知道。我觉得挺——
Yeah, you're right. You're never going to win. Which is the award with the circle that spins around? Is that the Tony, Sean? Yeah. Right, does it spin? It does spin. It does.
对，你说的对。你永远不会赢。那个带旋转圆圈的奖项是什么？那是托尼奖吗，肖恩？对。对，它会旋转吗？它确实会旋转。会的。
Wait, do you have it there or is it in LA? It's in LA. The Grammy's the one with the horn, yep. By the way, it's so funny. That's the gravaphone, yeah. With the horn. It the way, it's so funny. That's the gramophone, yeah. With the horn. It's funny, and sometimes you just sit back and just. Just marvel.
等等，你把它放在那里还是在洛杉矶？在洛杉矶。格莱美奖是那个带喇叭的，对。顺便说一句，太搞笑了。那是留声机，对。带喇叭的。顺便说一句，太搞笑了。那是留声机，对。带喇叭的。太搞笑了，有时候你只需要往后一靠，然后去……只需惊叹。
Just point the pointer, and these two little kiddies, they just go all over the room. And you just point the pointer. And watch them chase them. A little wall of yarn. I usually ask people if they have any crazy theater stories, but in this case, do you have any crazy theater stories, but in this case, do you have any crazy fan stories
只需指指点点，这两只小可爱，它们就在房间到处跑。而你只需要指指点点。看着它们追逐。一小面毛线墙。我通常会问别人有没有什么疯狂的剧院故事，但这次，你有没有什么疯狂的剧院故事，但这次，你有没有什么疯狂的粉丝故事
that you have that any kind of insane, out of all of the, well, out of all the touring you've done for sure, but of the specials or the tour, where just somebody insane didn't ever stop. Yeah, no, there's, I mean, there's definitely, you guys were talking about, I feel like I'm so goofy looking, so like I'm very recognizable if you know who I am.
那种疯狂的、出格的经历，在你所有的巡演经历中肯定是有的，但在专场或巡演中，有没有哪个疯狂的人一直没完没了。对，没有，有，我是说，绝对是有的，你们刚才在聊，我觉得我长得太滑稽了，所以如果你知道我是谁，我辨识度非常高。
You look like John America. That's what you look like. But like a pale version of it. So it's like I'm either the guy that shovels your driveway or I'm Jim Gaffigan, right? So there is, so I could be, and I have horrible vision, so, but because I'm pale and goofy looking, people can see me from far away.
看起来你就像是美国约翰。你看起来就是这样。但有点像是个苍白版。所以要么我是那个帮你铲车道积雪的人，要么我是吉姆·加菲根，对吧？所以，我可以是，而且我视力极差，所以，但因为我脸色苍白，看起来傻乎乎的，人们老远就能看到我。
They're like, oh, is that, hey, is that Jim Gaffigan? And I can't see who they are because I'm blind, but. But you've been loved and on television or some form of media for so long, you must not be able to walk down the street often without getting stopped or going, hey, hey, that's, hey. Yeah, do you get a lot of that?
他们会觉得，哦，那是，嘿，那是吉姆·加菲根吗？而我因为是个瞎子，看不清他们是谁，不过。但你这么长时间以来一直深受喜爱，而且经常上电视或出现在某种形式的媒体上，你走在街上时，一定经常被人拦住，或者听到有人喊，嘿，嘿，那是，嘿。没错，你经常遇到这种情况吗？
Yeah, a lot, you know, like I'm playing, I'm, you know, I've provided them a riddle. You know what I mean? Like, hey, do I, how am I supposed to know you? And you're like. Yeah, you catch a lot of people just staring at you from across the room, trying to figure it out. Especially in strip clubs. They're always like, who is that guy?
是的，经常，你知道，就像我在演，我是在，你知道，我给他们留了个谜题。你知道我的意思吗？就像，嘿，我，我怎么会认识你？而你会觉得。没错，你会发现很多人只是在房间的那头盯着你看，试图认出你来。尤其是在脱衣舞俱乐部。他们总是会想，那家伙是谁？
Yeah, because it's too dark in there. And you're really making it. You got five kids, what are you doing here? Yeah. Trying to get a six kit. Yeah, they take their phone out, click. No, but you were maybe going to tell us, go down the story.
对，因为里面太黑了。而且你真的把这气氛……你都有五个孩子了，你在这儿干嘛呢？对啊。想生第六个吗？对，他们掏出手机，咔嚓。不，不过你刚才也许正要跟我们说，讲讲那个故事。
Oh yeah, you know what I would say is, you know, there is a theater story. I did that championship season on Broadway. And it was, the amount of testosterone in the cast was absolutely insane. It was me, Kiefer Sutherland, Brian Cox, Chris Noth, and Jason Patrick, whose dad wrote the play. And so it's a great play.
哦对，你知道我想说的是，你知道，有个关于戏剧的故事。我在百老汇演过《大牌》。当时，剧组里的雄性荷尔蒙简直多得疯狂。里面有我、基弗·萨瑟兰、布莱恩·考克斯、克里斯·诺斯，还有贾森·帕特里克，他的父亲写了这部剧。所以这是一部很棒的剧。
And it was, but like, so like, when you talk about theater stories, we went, I mean, it's also like this last, I think of like, there's this last generation of people that, and there's a segment of this generation that drink like our parents did, and those guys are those guys. And so every night, we would, every night was like a,
而且，但是，当你们聊起戏剧故事时，我们去过，我的意思是，这也让我想起，我觉得，有这样最后一代人，这一代人里有一部分人喝酒就像我们的父辈一样，而那几个家伙就是那种人。所以每天晚上，我们都会，每一晚都像是一个，
it was, the stamina is just bizarre. Like, these guys can throw it away and then get up and do a matinee. And I was just like, I can barely walk. Yeah, I know. But I wonder how that's, I'd love to check in on those fellas now and see how it's aging.
那体力简直不可思议。真的，这帮家伙能通宵喝大酒，然后还能爬起来演日场。而我当时的感觉是，我简直快走不动了。没错，我懂。不过我很想知道，我现在好想去打听一下那几个家伙现在怎么样了，看看他们是怎么变老的。
Cause at some point you do pay the bill. Yeah. You know, just the stamina isn't forever. Well, I'm sure they're all doing, but like they were, it was so bizarre to go out on stage, because I always had this vision of Broadway being, oh my, you know, like people in top hats and stuff like that.
因为总归有一天你要付出代价。对啊。你知道的，体力总不会永远那么好。好吧，我敢肯定他们现在都挺好的，不过，就像他们那样，上台演出真的太诡异了，因为我对百老汇一直有一种幻想，哦天哪，你知道的，就像人们戴着高顶礼帽之类的那种。
And it's like, people would walk out and people are like, 24, a section this, you know, it was just bizarre how it was. It was that people were going to so they could see Mr. Big. Right, right, right, right, right. But yeah, people really, really like it. But your earlier standup stuff,
而现实是，人们会走出来，然后大家会说，24号，这个区，你知道的，那种场景简直诡异。人们去那儿其实就是为了看大人物先生。对，对，对，对，对。不过是的，人们真的非常非常喜欢它。但是你早期的单口喜剧，
do you, is there, when you were first starting, is there, do you tend to remember the good performances more than the bad ones, Or are you like the other? I try to block out some really humiliating things. But I did a show on Long Island at Governor's. And Long Island is great, but parts of Long Island, it can be not necessarily combative, but just kind of, and I would walk on stage
你觉得，有没有这样的时候，当你刚开始的时候，你往往更容易记住那些精彩的演出，而不是糟糕的演出，还是说你跟其他人一样？我试着把一些真正羞辱人的事情从记忆里抹去。但我曾在长岛的“总督”喜剧俱乐部演出过。长岛很棒，但长岛的某些地方，氛围可能不一定是充满敌意的，但就是那种，而且我走上台时，
when I started looking like the farm boy that I wanted to be, and these New Yorkers would be like, look at this guy, you know what I mean? And so early 90s comedy was very combat-driven, like this guy's just a pussy. You know what I mean? And so I remember I was on stage, it was a late show at Governor's, and I got on stage, and someone in the audience was mooing.
刚开始时我看起来就像我心目中那种纯朴的农场男孩，而这些纽约人就会说，看看这家伙，你知道我的意思吗？所以90年代初的喜剧非常具有对抗性，就像“这家伙就是个怂货”那种。你知道我的意思吗？所以我记得当时我在台上，那是“总督”俱乐部的深夜场，我一上台，观众席里就有人在学牛叫。
They were actually mooing. Moo, moo, and I was like, oh, this is great, okay. So, because I'm from Indiana, they're mooing. And so then I tried to, you know, deal with the heckler. And normally, you know, you have a microphone, you have an advantage, but it didn't really work. And so then eventually, there was enough slack on the microphone.
他们真的在学牛叫。哞，哞，然后我就想，哦，这太棒了，好吧。所以，因为我来自印第安纳州，他们在学牛叫。于是我就试着，你知道的，去应付这个起哄的人。通常情况下，你知道的，你手里有麦克风，你占有优势，但实际上并没有什么用。然后最终，麦克风的线拉得够长了。
So I walked into the audience to find out who this mooing person was. And there was somebody severely handicapped lying in a hospital bed who could only articulate. No, Jim. Only communicate by going moo. No. So I had spent a good 20 minutes
所以我走进了观众席，想找出这个学牛叫的人到底是谁。结果发现是一个严重残疾的人躺在病床上，只能发出。不，吉姆。只能通过发出“哞”的声音来表达。不。所以我花了足足20分钟，
tearing into this severely disabled. Like they had like the keyboard and everything. And I'm just like, but the crowd had known. And I was like, all right, I'm just going to kill myself. And they were very forgiving and the person loved the attention. But that was probably one of the more terrible situations. That's quite a story.
对着这个重度残疾的人破口大骂。就像他们有那种键盘什么的。然后我就想，但其实全场观众都知道。当时我就想，好吧，我干脆自杀算了。他们人其实非常好，而且那个人也很享受这种关注。但这可能是我经历过的最可怕的情况之一了。这真是一个了不起的故事。
Sean, have you learned your lesson? Never ask that question again. Yeah, I'm like, compare these things. Wow. Now, do you have a clear, I'm sorry if you've answered this question a million times, but do you have a clear preference between standup and acting?
肖恩，你吸取教训了吗？永远不要再问那个问题了。对，我感觉像是在。对比这些事情。哇。现在，你有没有一个明确的——如果这个问题你已经被问过无数次了，我很抱歉——但你对单口喜剧和演戏之间有没有明显的偏爱？
Because you've done tons of both. One, the words come beforehand, the other, the words come after. I love doing both of them because I think that stand up is such a bizarre existence at night and stuff like that. And it's so solitary and it can, whereas the collaborative thing of acting is so amazing. But I think the process of getting acting jobs is so maddening that I would totally lose my mind
因为这两样你都做过无数次。一个，台词在前面；另一个，台词在后面。我两样都很喜欢，因为我觉得单口喜剧在晚上的那种存在方式太诡异了诸如此类的。而且它是如此孤独，并且可能，而演戏那种合作的氛围是如此奇妙。但我觉得争取演艺工作的过程实在是太让人抓狂了，以至于我完全会精神崩溃，
if I had to rely just on that emotionally. Yeah, I mean, some of us, yeah, it's job security to have created an audience. You can control, in one lane of your career, you are fully in control of that. You can sit down and write some great stuff. You can get the creative fulfillment. Whereas, you know, I've done a lot of dramas,
如果我在情感上只能依靠那个的话。是的，我的意思是，我们中的一些人，是的，建立起自己的观众群体就是一种工作保障。你可以在你的职业生涯中掌控其中一条赛道，你可以完全掌控它。你可以坐下来写一些很棒的东西。你可以获得创作上的满足感。然而，你知道的，我演过很多正剧，
but to this day, I had a meeting two days ago, and I've done tons of dramas, and people are always, they all have the idea of, what if we put Jim Gaffigan in a drama? And I'm like, all right, I mean, most of them have been indies, but I'm like, and you want to be polite and go,
但直到今天，我两天前还开会来着，我演过大量的正剧，而人们总是，他们脑子里全都有这样一个想法：如果我们把吉姆·加菲根放到一部正剧里会怎么样？而我就想，好吧，我的意思是，其中大多数都是独立电影，但我就想，你还想表现得礼貌一点说，
yeah, sure, that would be great, even though like, I've done it. I've been doing that for a long time. Yeah, for sure, for sure. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Do any of your kids share the business tree passion? Yeah, I think, you know,
好的，当然，那太棒了，尽管事实上——我已经演过了。我做这一行已经很久了。对，当然，当然。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。你的孩子们有谁继承了这门手艺的热情吗？是的，我想，你知道的，
I've toured doing standup with my 18 year old son. He's really funny. Oh, no way. So like he opens for you or closes for you or together? Yeah, he's done, yeah. Oh really, that's cool. It's, you know, last couple spring breaks, we've done that, but it's such a weird business.
我曾带着我18岁的儿子一起去巡演做单口喜剧。他真的很有趣。哦，不会吧。所以，他是为你暖场，还是为你压轴，还是你们一起？对，他做过，对。哦真的吗，那太酷了。这，你知道的，过去几个春假，我们都这么做了，但这真是一个奇怪的行业。
It's like, and my oldest daughter, who's 20, really loves acting, and I'm like, you know there's no jobs, right? There's just, you wanna, and so I'm like, if you want it, you have to create your own jobs. So I'm like, I'll pay for film school, but like there's no, you know. Right, it's not like it used to be.
就像是，我20岁的大女儿非常喜欢演戏，而我就对她说，你知道这里根本没有工作对吧？这里只有，你想……所以我就说，如果你真的想要，你必须自己创造工作机会。所以我告诉她，我会出钱让你去上电影学校，但除此之外，你知道的。没错，现在和过去不一样了。
Yeah, it's. It is a tough thing, cause you can't walk around with that diploma and sort of guarantee yourself at least an entry level position. No, it's so cruel. But it's even different from it used to be like you talked about pilot season.
对，它。这确实是一件很难的事，因为你不能拿着那张文凭到处走，然后就能保证自己至少能得到一份入门级的工作。不，这太残酷了。但它甚至和过去不一样了，就像你之前提到的试播集季。
Yeah, and commercials. You could have been able to live both. Commercials, you did commercials. When I was a young actor, I supported myself doing voiceovers. Did a ton of voiceovers in and around New York. And then every year by about January for a few years, I would fly out to California.
对，还有广告。你以前可以靠这两样东西生活。广告，你拍过广告。当我还是个年轻演员时，我是靠做画外音来养活自己的。在纽约及其周边地区做过大量的画外音。然后每年大约一月份，连续好几年，我都会飞到加州去。
Well, not every year. Sometimes I would go for like a month, and sometimes, but you'd have pilot, at least pilot auditions, couple a day here in New York, and you'd do the circuit, right? You'd go to all the places, and then they'd fly you out, and there was like, there was a good chance, once you kind of got in the mix,
好吧，也不是每年。有时我会去呆上一个月，有时，但你会有试播集，至少有试播集试镜，在纽约这边一天有好几场，你要跑遍所有这些地方，然后他们会把你飞机接到那边去，而且那种感觉是，一旦你融入了这个圈子，
there was a good chance you'd get a job, you'd get a pilot every year. And wasn't the Arrested Development year like the last year you were gonna do this goddamn pilgrimage out to Los Angeles for pilot season? No, I got fired the year before and I wasn't gonna do it and I didn't audition for any pilot.
你很有可能会得到一份工作，每年都会接到一部试播集。难道《发展受阻》那年不是你最后一次去洛杉矶进行该死的试播集朝圣之旅吗？不，我在那之前一年被解雇了，我本来不打算去的，我也没有去参加任何试播集的试镜。
And Deb Burelski reached out and said, oh come on Will, please just put yourself on TV or something like that. Yeah, meanwhile I was like, I'm not gonna do the TV industry, they're really gonna feel the pain of me not being around. Would you blame me?
然后黛布·布雷尔斯基（Deb Burelski）联系了我，说，哦，拜托，威尔，求求你了，至少把你的录像带弄到电视上或者类似的地方去吧。对，与此同时我的反应是：我才不要搞电视行业呢，他们真的会深刻体会到没有我在身边的痛苦。你会怪我吗？
Wait till I show them. Right. I think Arrested Development, I tested for that. Or I was, or maybe not a network test, but a studio test. What part? I think the David Cross one. Yeah? Okay.
等着我给他们点颜色看看。对。我想《发展受阻》，我曾为那个试镜过。或者我是，也许不是电视台试镜，而是工作室试镜。什么角色？我想是大卫·克罗斯那个角色。是吗？好吧。
But I think that... Oh my God, that would have been great... No, it's even worse than that. It was... Because there's also during pilot season there's like, do you want to commit to this pilot? Do you want them in first position? Yes. And I think I had been offered a pilot to be in first position and I was like, all right fine, you know, that yeah let's do that first position. It was garbage, but I'm like, all right, fine. I just want to act.
但我觉得……哦天哪，那本来会很棒的……不，比那还要糟糕。那是……因为在试播集季期间还有这样的情况：你想签约这部试播集吗？你想让他们拥有第一顺位选择权吗？是的。我想我当时已经接到了一份试播集的邀约，要占据第一顺位，而我的反应是：好吧，好吧，你知道的，那就把第一顺位给他们吧。那是个垃圾剧本，但我想，好吧，行吧。我只是想演戏。
And then, because I had worked with Mitch Hurwitz the year before on Ellen DeGeneres' sitcom, and he's like, hey, why don't you come in and audition for this? Because I had been schmoozing him to get a part on it, because obviously he's brilliant, right, and so, and then he was like, yeah, you're in first position, and this is a low budget thing,
然后，因为我前一年和米奇·赫尔维茨（Mitch Hurwitz）在艾伦·德杰尼勒斯的情景喜剧中合作过，他就说，嘿，你为什么不来为这个试镜呢？因为我之前一直在拍他的马屁想在里面混个角色，因为很显然他是天才，对吧，所以，然后他就说，好吧，你现在是第一顺位，而这是一个低预算的项目，
we can't have anyone in, because we're going to do it, because remember the premise was like that they were going to do it in a different way. Remember he wrote that cover letter on it? Yeah, if you want a dressing room larger than a honey wagon this job's not for you. Don't even bother auditioning. Mike Terry who works on our show, whom you met,
我们不能让任何人进来，因为我们要这么做，因为还记得那个前提吗，他们打算用一种不同的方式来拍。还记得他写的那封附信吗？对，如果你想要一个比拖车大一点的化妆室，那这工作不适合你。甚至都别费劲来试镜了。迈克·特里（Mike Terry），在我们节目工作的那个，你见过的，
he sent me, his wife worked for Deb Burelski, I think it was. He sent me recently the list of people, and my name's on it, of people who were sent, because I eventually put myself on tape here in New York. I was doing a play in New York, and I was so bummed about being fired from this show the year before
他发给我——他老婆当时好像是在黛布·布雷尔斯基手下工作。他最近把那份名单发给了我，上面有我的名字，那是当时被派去的人的名单，因为我最终在纽约这边自己录了试镜带。我当时在纽约演一出戏，而且我对前一年被那部剧开除这事感到非常沮丧，
that I was like, I'm not going to do another, I'm done, fuck sitcoms, I don't do that. Beneath, like I kind of tried to flip it in my mind that I'm above it, because don't do that. Beneath me, like I kind of tried to flip it in my mind that I'm above it because I'd been fired. And anyway, so I went and I read for Deborah Rouske, but Mike just sent me, I've got it in my office at home. Wow. Yeah, the sign-in sheet or whatever.
以至于我当时想：我再也不拍别的了，我受够了，去他的情景喜剧，我再也不干了。在心底里——我其实试图在脑子里扭曲这种心态，假装自己高人一等，因为别这么干。自命不凡，我其实试图在脑子里扭曲这种心态，假装自己高人一等，因为我被开除了。不管怎样，后来我还是去给黛布拉·罗斯克（Deborah Rouske）试读了，但迈克刚把那个发给我，我家里办公室里还留着呢。哇。对，签到表什么的。
Mitch sent me the videotape of my actual audition for Michael Bluth. I've got it on my computer. Wow. And that was the last day you ate, right? Like that's why you started. Yeah, I've been it on my computer. Wow. And that was the last day you ate, right? Like, and that's why you still. Yeah, I've been swimming ever since. I just look too puffy.
米奇把我的迈克尔·布鲁斯（Michael Bluth）实际试镜录像发给了我。我的电脑里还存着呢。哇。那也是你最后一天吃饭的日子对吧？所以你才开始……对，我把存电脑里了。哇。那也是你最后一天吃饭的日子对吧？所以你才开始……对，我从那以后一直在游泳。我只是看起来有点胖乎乎的。
Jim, I forgot that you were on that Ellen show with Mitch that year before, I remember that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Martin Moll was on that show, that was so. We loved Martin Moll. It was so, I mean, he was such a sweet guy. And he was. such a sweet guy. And he was. Such a sweet guy.
吉姆，我差点忘了你前一年和米奇一起演过那部艾伦的剧，我记得那个。对，对，对。马丁·莫尔（Martin Mull）也参演了那部剧，真是太……我们太爱马丁·莫尔了。太……我的意思是，他真的是个太好的人了。而且他。真的是个太好的人了。而且他。真的是个太好的人了。
And it was so bizarre to see this guy that I had watched on Fernwood Tonight. Yeah, Fernwood Tonight was great. I mean it was just, and you know, I mean I know I'm older than you guys, but like you have to understand, that was this, that was the bizarre, him and Fred Willard, that was like my first exposure to like bizarre comedy.
而且能看到这个我曾在《费恩伍德今夜秀》（Fernwood Tonight）里看过的演员，感觉太诡异了。对，《费恩伍德今夜秀》太棒了。我的意思是，那简直是，而且你知道，我虽然知道我比你们年纪都大，但你们得明白，那就是，那是那种诡异的体验，他和弗雷德·威拉德（Fred Willard），那是我第一次接触到那种诡异风格的喜剧。
And they did like cutting edge super racy. It was so clever because it was, I loved that show. Well also, I had no idea that Martin Mull was this brilliant painter. Like he went to art school to be a painter and then he would just tell stories about Steve Martin, which was amazing. Cause you know.
而且他们做的是那种前卫、超级带劲的内容。它太聪明了，因为它就是，我太爱那个节目了。另外，我完全不知道马丁·莫尔竟然是个如此才华横溢的画家。他上艺术学校就是为了当画家，然后他总是讲一些关于史蒂夫·马丁的故事，太棒了。因为你知道的。
Jason, is that a mall behind you? Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's a mall right there. A mall. I got this one cheap. Jim, tell me about like unusual jobs before you got all this work when you were starting. I started off, well, I studied finance, but then.
贾森，你身后那个是购物中心吗？对，对，对。那后面就是一个购物中心。一个购物中心。我这个买得很便宜。吉姆，跟我讲讲在你获得所有这些工作、刚开始奋斗之前那些不寻常的工作吧。我一开始，嗯，我学的是金融，但是后来。
That's wild, you went to school for finance. I was a copywriter in an advertising agency. Really? I think it was really helpful in learning some, you know, some word economy and efficiency of writing. But it was, I was the weird guy in the corporate setting, like Jim's crazy, you know, like he the weird guy in the corporate setting, like Jim's crazy. You know, like he's napping in his room.
这太疯狂了，你大学学的是金融。我曾在一家广告公司做过文案。真的吗？我觉得这对我学习某些东西非常有帮助，你知道的，比如词汇的精简和写作的效率。但当时，我在企业环境中是个怪人，就像“吉姆是个疯子”那种，你知道的，就像我是企业环境中的怪人，就像“吉姆是个疯子”。你知道的，他会在自己的办公室里打盹。
Meanwhile, I got like three hours of sleep the night before. But yeah, there was, I was definitely, I was the last of my friends to have a day job because I think the remnants of that retaining security had really stayed with me. And I also knew that I didn't want to just do some horrible bar gigs. And I tried to limit some of the humiliation. Do you keep up with financing?
与此同时，我前一晚只睡了三个小时。不过确实，我绝对是朋友里最后一个放弃朝九晚五正职的人，因为我觉得那种保留安全感的残余心理一直留在我身上。而且我也知道我不想去做那些糟糕的酒吧驻唱。我尽量避免一些羞辱。你现在还关注金融吗？
Is that still kind of like a hobby of yours? I didn't really. I still don't know anything about finance. And it's like I went to college and I even joke around about that in my new special. It's like, it's really sad. I mean, I have middle schoolers and I look at their math and I'm like, did they introduce new numbers? Because I don't know what's going on.
那现在还算是一种你的爱好吗？其实没有。我对金融依然一无所知。就像我上了大学，我甚至还在我的新专场里拿这个开玩笑。这真的很悲哀。我的意思是，我有些孩子在上初中，我看着他们的数学题心想：他们这是引进新数字了吗？因为我根本不知道他们在搞什么鬼。
And so, and also like if I looked at the Wall Street Journal financial section, I wouldn't know. And I probably passed a class in it. Yeah, got it. But speaking of your special, it's called The Skinny. It's on Hulu right now. Yes. Yes.
所以，而且如果我看《华尔街日报》的金融版，我也会完全看不懂。我可能当年还及格通过了一门这方面的课呢。对，明白了。不过说到你的专场，名字叫《极瘦》（The Skinny）。现在正在Hulu上播放。是的。是的。
And so this is number 11. This is the 11th special. Good Lord. Isn't that amazing? It's crazy, and I'm only 22. That's pretty impressive, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's pretty cool. What did you say, it's the 11th of 22?
所以这是第11部。这是你的第11个专场。天哪。这难道不惊人吗？太疯狂了，而且我才22岁。这真的很impressive（令人印象深刻），对，对，对。这太酷了。你刚才说什么，这是22部里的第11部？
You've decided you're gonna do- And I'm only 22 years old. No, he's only 22 years old. Where do you see, I mean, what do you, as a performer, do you see yourself as you sort of get older, that you want to keep making specials, do you like the process of making specials, or do you get a thing, do you see yourself as you sort of get older that you want to keep making specials? Do you like the process of making specials
你已经决定你要拍——而且我只有22岁。不，他才22岁。你觉得，我的意思是，作为一名表演者，随着年龄的增长，你觉得自己还会继续拍摄专场吗？你喜欢制作专场的整个过程吗？还是说，随着年龄的增长，你觉得自己会想继续制作专场吗？你喜欢制作专场的过程，
or do you get a thing where you're like, I just want to act more because the specials, I've kind of, I've done 11 of them and I don't, or does it, where does the fire live? It's all self assignment, right? Like every aspect of this business, right? There's, like we have this notion that someone's in a, sitting at a counter at a soda shop and someone comes up.
还是说你会遇到这样一种情况：你只想演更多戏，因为专场我已经拍了11部了，我不想……或者说，你的那股热情究竟在哪里？这一切都是自己给自己布置的任务，对吧？就像这个行业的方方面面一样，对吧？我们总有一种观念，好像有人正坐在苏打店的柜台前，然后有人走过来……
It's like you have to like steer it. You have to sit there and go, I want to do this. And, but what I love about writing stand up is that it's something I have control over. So it's like, look, I would, you know, I would love it if I didn't have time to do it as much as I do. But, and I have turned down a fair amount of,
这就好比你必须去掌控它。你必须坐在那里说：我想这么做。而且，我喜欢写单口喜剧的一点在于，这是我可以掌控的事情。所以你看，如果可以的话，我倒希望自己不要像现在这样抽不出那么多时间来做它。不过，而且我已经推掉相当一部分……
I mean, I love just complex characters and so if it's a good acting role, I'd love to do it. But like if it's some kind of silly comedy where I would have to do it, but like if it's, you know, some kind of silly comedy where I would have fun doing it, but it wouldn't be something great, you know, I try not to, and also I have kids, so I have to be very selective on why I'm going out of town, meaning I gotta make money.
我的意思是，我喜欢复杂的角色，所以如果是一个好的演艺角色，我很乐意去演。但如果是那种我必须去演的弱智喜剧，或者说，如果是那种，你知道的，某种我演起来会觉得好玩但算不上多棒的傻里傻气的喜剧，你知道的，我尽量不去接。而且我有孩子，所以我必须非常挑剔自己为什么要出远门，这意味着我得赚到钱。
But I do a lot of indies where I make nothing. Do you still go and jump on stage at the Comedy Seller and places like that? Absolutely, I try, that's why we're still in New York City. I mean, I wanted my kids to be New Yorkers, but also, it's so great I can just go and do a show at Gotham or the New York Comedy Club, and then I can be home and try and tear the screens
不过我也拍了很多片酬为零的独立电影。你现在还经常去喜剧细胞（Comedy Cellar）之类的地方上台串场吗？当然，我尽量去，这就是为什么我们依然留在纽约市的原因。我的意思是，我想让我的孩子们成为纽约客，而且，我能随时去哥谭喜剧俱乐部（Gotham）或纽约喜剧俱乐部（New York Comedy Club）演一场，然后回家试图把孩子们从屏幕前拉开，这种感觉太棒了。
away from the kids. Yeah, yeah. Your life sounds fricking perfect. I want to come back as Jim Gaffigan. I'm gonna do it. It's far from it, but thank you. What's your favorite non-comedy or non-businessy thing? I know you love gardening.
对，对。你的生活听起来简直完美无缺。我想下辈子投胎做吉姆·加菲根。我也想这么干。离完美还远得很呢，不过谢谢你。你最喜欢的非喜剧或非商业相关的事情是什么？我知道你喜欢园艺。
Yes, I do love gardening. Now where do you get a chance to do that downtown? During the pandemic, we got a place in Westchester. Oh, okay. And so, and they had some raised beds there and I love that, but I love gardening. And during the pandemic, I got into bourbon. I just, if I'm talking to like three people
是的，我确实很喜欢园艺。那你现在在哪儿有机会在市中心做这个呢？疫情期间，我们在威斯特彻斯特买了个地方。哦，好吧。所以，那里有一些高架花坛，我真的很喜欢，我太爱园艺了。而在疫情期间，我迷上了波旁威士忌。我只是，如果我和娱乐行业的两三个人聊天，
in the entertainment industry, I assume two of you don't drink any longer, you know? But like, so it's like, but like, so I was like a beer guy. And then during the pandemic, I kind of got into bourbon. And then, I mean, we've all probably been approached. Maybe you guys have a celebrity spirit, but I didn't want to do that.
我假设你们俩已经不喝酒了，你知道的吗？但所以，就像，但我以前是个啤酒客。然后在疫情期间，我开始迷上波旁威士忌。然后，我的意思是，我们大概都曾被找过。也许你们俩都有自己的名人烈酒品牌，但我不想那样做。
But I have a buddy from Louisville, I'm already a spirit, but I didn't wanna do that. So, but I have a buddy from Louisville and I was like, can't, because some of them are just so bad. So I was like, can't we just pick our own and do this? And he's like, you might just end up with a bunch of barrels of a bunch of bottles of bourbon. I'm like, that's fine. So I'm doing that till I eventually join AA, I guess in three years.
不过我有个来自路易斯安那州路易斯维尔的朋友，我本来就已经是个烈酒品牌了，但我不想那样做。所以，但我有个来自路易斯维尔的朋友，我就在想——因为有些酒实在是太烂了。所以我就问，难道我们不能自己挑一款然后来做这个吗？他回答说：你最后可能只会得到一堆装满波旁威士忌的酒桶和酒瓶。我说：那没问题。所以我一直在这么干，直到我最终加入匿名戒酒互助会（AA），大概在三年后吧。
I don't know. Turn to profit first, yeah. That's great. Like saying I went from beer and then I got into bourbon, it's like saying I used to do Coke and then I got into crack. Right, you know, it's just, fuck it.
我不知道。先把利润搞到手，对吧。太棒了。就像说我以前喝啤酒，然后我开始迷上波旁威士忌，这简直就像是在说我以前吸可卡因，然后我开始迷上快克可卡因一样。没错，你知道的，管他呢。
Ketamine is great, it's just a starting point. Well, they always say I'm drinking bourbon in the morning, but it's actual apple juice on the rocks. Oh, there you go. Of course it is. By the way, every step of the way, Jim, Sean will out Midwest you in every respect. You can't believe how from the fucking,
氯胺酮（K粉）挺棒的，那只是个起点。好吧，人们总是说我早上在喝波旁威士忌，但其实那是加冰的苹果汁。哦，原来如此。当然是啦。顺便说一句，吉姆，在方方面面，肖恩都会把你的中西部特质压下去。你简直无法想象他有多么来自那该死的……
do you see how excited he was when he was like, and you're from Oakmont, right? You're wherever. Yeah, I'll tell you that. I'm from 20 minutes away from there. And we're always like, isn't I'm from 20 minutes away from there. And we're always like, isn't that fucking crazy? People are from places.
你看他刚才有多兴奋，当他说“你是从奥克芒来的吧？你在哪个哪个地方”。对，我告诉你。我离那儿只有20分钟车程。我们总是会觉得——我离那儿只有20分钟车程。我们总是会觉得：这他妈不疯狂吗？人们来自各个地方。
I'm always fascinated that people get out of the place they live to pursue their dreams in other places. I love those stories. Sean, really quick, lunch today, Sean, really quick, what's on the menu, quickly. Scotty, what's for lunch, mac and cheese? He's chopping celery for the egg salad right now. Yeah, I think it's going to be, I think it's going to be Kraft Mac and Cheese. He's chopping celery for the egg salad right now. Yeah. What is it?
我总是对人们离开他们居住的地方去其他地方追求梦想这件事感到着迷。我太喜欢这些故事了。肖恩，快点，今天的午餐，肖恩，快点，菜单上有什么，快说。斯科蒂，午餐吃什么，通心粉加奶酪吗？他现在正在为鸡蛋沙拉切芹菜呢。对，我想这会是，我想这会是卡夫通心粉加奶酪。他现在正在为鸡蛋沙拉切芹菜。对。是什么？
I think it's gonna be Kraft Mac and Cheese. So you can still eat like you're in third grade and you look great. A little bit. Wow. I've always got a cookie pouch. Show them the cookie pouch. I got a cookie pouch. There it is.
我想会是卡夫通心粉加奶酪。所以你吃东西依然像个三年级的小学生，而且你看上去状态极佳。有一点吧。哇。我随时都带着一个曲奇袋。给他们看看那个曲奇袋。我有个曲奇袋。看，就在这儿。
Here it comes. Oh, there you go. That's it. It's my cookie pouch. No, I thought it was... Growing up in the Midwest, I used to look around and be like, I mean I know I wanted to be a farmer and everything, but like, I was like, oh, I think there's,
它来了。哦，好了。就是这个。这是我的曲奇袋。不，我还以为……在中西部长大的时候，我经常环顾四周心想：我的意思是，我知道我想当个农夫什么的，但是，我当时想，哦，我想，
I used to, oh, there's been a mistake, I'm not supposed to be here, I'm supposed to be in New York. And then I got to New York and I was like, oh, well I'm finally home, and they're like, you're the most Midwestern looking guy I've ever seen in my life. So, I realized how Midwestern I was when I left the Midwest. Because we look plain, we look plain.
我以前会想，哦，搞错了，我不该呆在这里，我应该去纽约。然后我到了纽约，心想，哦，好吧，我终于到家了，而他们却说：“你是我这辈子见过最有中西部长相的人。”所以，我是在离开中西部之后才意识到自己有多么中西部的。因为我们看起来很朴素，我们看起来很朴素。
We look plain, we blend in. And it's a sexiness, right? Like people think Midwestern, they think sex is, you know, Tim Walls sexy, you know, and stuff like that. Yeah, snap the overalls and let's get after it. Sean, Sean, be honest. How long between now and when are you, have you started looking at rascals online?
我们看起来很朴素，我们能融入人群。这是一种性感，对吧？就像人们一想到中西部，就会觉得性感，你知道的，蒂姆·沃尔兹（Tim Walz）很性感，你知道的，诸如此类。对，扣上工装裤的背带，让我们开始大干一场吧。肖恩，肖恩，说实话。距离现在还有多久，你有没有开始在网上看那种代步电动车？
Are you like, what speed am I gonna get? Yeah, yeah, I'm looking at it right now. Are you just eating your way into a rascal right now? Is that the end goal? You put special tires on that, mags or anything, spinners. Yeah. Jim, you're the greatest. Oh, well thanks for being here today. It's such a funny day. Yeah, you're the greatest. Oh, well, thanks.
你会想：“我能开多快？”对，对，我正在看呢。你是不是正一路狂吃，直到自己不得不坐上电动代步车？这就是终极目标吗？你会给那车换上特制轮胎、电镀轮毂或者加装旋转轮毂吗？吉姆，你太棒了。哦，谢谢你今天能来。今天太逗了。对，你太棒了。哦，好吧，谢谢。
Thanks for being here today. It's such a funny day. Yeah, very nice of you to spend some time with us. I appreciate it. We're all big fans of you. Yeah, you're such a consistently. Next steak dinner, you know, when I wait, you know, your table, please tip.
谢谢你今天能来。今天太逗了。对，你花时间陪我们聊聊真是太好了。我很感激。我们都是你的超级粉丝。对，你一直以来都这么稳定。下次牛排晚餐，你知道的，当我在等的时候，你知道的，你的桌子，请付小费。
You know what I mean? Some of it's for the bus boys. And we'll act like- Will's going to pick it up next time. Next, I'm going to pick it up all the time. Jim, would you, if we're ever here in New York again and we say, hey, we're gonna go to Strip House, would you join us?
你知道我的意思吗？一部分是要给服务生的。然后我们会假装——威尔下次会买单的。下次，我每次都会买单的。吉姆，如果你以后再来纽约，我们说“嘿，我们要去牛排之屋（Strip House）”，你愿意和我们一起去吗？
I would totally do that. Okay, I would love to see a set at Gotham first. No, I love it, because there's certain excuses, like when I go out with Seinfeld, I'm like, it's like Jerry wants me to have pizza and my wife's like, I understand, but if I'm just hanging out, there has to be a reason behind it.
我完全愿意。好的，不过我希望先去哥谭喜剧俱乐部看你的一场演出。不，我太喜欢了，因为总有些借口，比如当我和宋飞（Seinfeld）一起出去时，我的反应就像是杰瑞想让我吃披萨，而我妻子会说：我理解，但如果我只是闲逛，那背后必须得有个理由。
And you guys are very high status. Wow. Sure. We're worth the cholesterol. I love it. Jimmy, the skinny. The skinny. The skinny on Hulu, thanks for being here, pal.
而你们俩的社会地位太高了。哇。确实。我们对得起胆固醇。我太喜欢了。吉姆，《极瘦》。《极瘦》。在Hulu上看的《极瘦》，谢谢你能来，老兄。
We love you and thanks for making us laugh for 75 years. Thanks, dude. Thanks, Jim. Thanks, Jim. Bye. See you, bud. Will, I think you look 12. Thank you. That's my opinion.
我们爱你，谢谢你75年来一直逗我们笑。谢谢，老兄。谢谢你，吉姆。谢谢你，吉姆。再见。再见啦，兄弟。威尔，我觉得你看上去才12岁。谢谢。这就是我的看法。
I can't believe he said that. I really, it found it very hurtful. And you know what? And he started, he kicked the door down with it, didn't he? Started right out with it. You know why? I think he's got a crush on me.
我真不敢相信他会这么说。我真的，觉得这非常伤人。你知道吗？而且他一开始，一上来就直接破门而入，不是吗？一开场就直奔主题。你知道为什么吗？我觉得他有点迷恋我。
Yeah, you are a little intended. That's the way I got to frame it. I'm proud of you for working right through that. That could have wrecked the whole interview, but no, you didn't let it happen. I love that he doubled down on it. He did over and over. With the Gavin Newsom.
对，你确实有点讨人喜欢。这就是我必须得给自己找的借口。我为你能够顶住压力继续录制感到骄傲。那本来可能会毁了整个采访，但没有，你没让它发生。我喜欢他一再坚持这一点。他反反复复地这么说。扯到了加文·纽森（Gavin Newsom）。
It's my kind of joke. It's my kind of, I love it so much. Gavin Newsom's It's my kind of joke. It's my kind of, I love it so much. Gavin Newsom's dad? Dad. I don't. I'm so good. Mr. Newsom, Mr. Newsom. Oh, he's doing a new sitcom called Mr. Newsom.
这正是我的笑话风格。这正是我的，我太喜欢了。加文·纽森的……爸爸？爸爸。我可不去。我太棒了。纽森先生，纽森先生。哦，他正在拍一部新情景喜剧叫《纽森先生》。
Yeah, you know, you should send your headshot to Lorne Michaels if Newsom makes a run at it on the next election cycle. Isn't he, he's one of those guys, when you watch him doing a special, like you said't he, he's one of those guys, when you watch him doing a special, like you said, Jason, he's so calm. He's not like a loud in your face kind of, right?
对，你知道的，如果纽森在下一次选举周期里参选的话，你应该把你的演员简历照（headshot）寄给洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）。他不就是那种人在看他表演专场时——就像你说的，贾森，他太冷静了。他不是那种大喊大叫、咄咄逼人的人，对吧？
Yeah, you see how you just kind of start with a grin. He doesn't even need to be talking yet. He's authentic and he's such a nice guy too. My guy, I love him. He's so nice. Yeah, I love him. Huge, huge fan. I'm glad we had him.
对，你看他总是带着微笑开始。他甚至都还不需要开口说话。他很真实，而且他人也真的很好。我的哥们儿，我太爱他了。他人太好了。对，我爱死他了。超级超级粉丝。我很高兴我们能请到他。
I'm trying to think of a buy. Okay. And I looked up- Finally, seeing your honesty. Finally, by the way, look at this photo that just got sent. Oh my God. Is that Ricky?
我在想要怎么说“再见”。好吧。我查了一下——终于看到你的诚实了。顺便说一句，看看刚刚发来的这张照片。哦天哪。那是里奇（Ricky）吗？
Wait, so you looked up synonyms? Yes. Or cinnamon treats. I cut you off. What happened? I have two tabs open. Okay. Cinnabons near me.
等等，所以你查了同义词？是的。或者是肉桂卷。我打断你了。怎么回事？我开了两个标签页。好吧。离我最近的Cinnabon肉桂卷。
By the way, that sounds so good. Right? Yeah, I love that. Well, just after mac and cheese, you guys can jump in a cab. Yeah, I love mac and cheese. So there mac and cheese, you guys can jump in a cab. Yeah, I love mac and cheese. So there's like, there's via, there's through, there's a cross, there's a long, there's near,
顺便说一句，听起来太棒了。对吧？对，我太喜欢了。好吧，刚吃完通心粉加奶酪，你们俩就可以直接跳上出租车了。对，我太喜欢通心粉加奶酪了。所以有，有via（通过），有through（穿过），有across（横跨），有along（沿着），有near（附近），
there's a beyond, there's also a by. Synonyms to by, right? Yeah. Well, but what you did is you spelt it wrong. Oh, I did spell it wrong. The prompt needs to be B-Y-E. I did spell it wrong! Oh my God.
有beyond（超越），还有一个by。关于“by”的同义词，对吧？对。好吧，但你拼错了。哦，我确实拼错了。提示词应该是B-Y-E（再见）。我确实拼错啦！哦天哪。
Okay, ready? So there's a do, adios, a rivadierci, a raw, off-eater thing. There's cheerio. No, but we need, sorry, you did not understand the concept. You need to put the word by into the by. We don't need a synonym. A rivadierci is not gonna help you get to a by.
好吧，准备好了吗？所以有一个do，adios（西班牙语再见），arrivederci（意大利语再见），raw，还有别的乱七八糟的。还有cheerio（再见）。不对，但是我们需要，抱歉，你没有理解这个概念。你需要把“by”这个词放进……我们不需要同义词。“Arrivederci”可帮不了你走到一个“by”。
We've been doing it so long. Yeah. I want to blow my brains out. You want to blow your brains out. So whatever we come up with, fine. But for our audience, we just got to make sure that they buy it! Oh man, that snuck off on me. Buy it!
我们做这个都这么久了。对。我想去死。你想去死。所以无论我们想出什么都行。但为了我们的观众，我们必须确保他们买账！哦天哪，这把我给坑了。买账！
That was good, that was really good. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. Smart. Less. Armjärv and Bennett Barbeco. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这太棒了，真的太棒了。聪明。无双。聪明无双（SmartLess）由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿尔马约夫（Rob Armjarf）以及贝内特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbico）100%有机手工打造。聪明。无双。阿尔马约夫和贝内特·巴尔比科。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。